another blast of snow is on track for
millions of Americans in the Midwest
it's right on the tail of another storm
system that dumped snow throughout the
region Friday including more than a foot
in some areas around Chicago the winter
weather has grounded more than 1900
flights nationwide since Friday morning
Dean Reynolds is at O'Hare Airport this
morning where travelers are hoping
things get back on track today good
morning Dean
good morning nearly 900 of those
canceled flights were connected to
O'Hare additional flights were scrubbed
at Midway and the trouble was not
limited to air travel as the snow piled
up so did the cars and trucks on
Interstate 94 east of Kalamazoo Michigan
a chain reaction crash involving more
than 50 vehicles shut the highway down
for hours while no one was seriously
hurt there were some close calls truck
driver Robert row narrowly avoided a
serious crash when I saw I was gonna hit
him I was like well okay which way can I
go and the ditch was the only other
alternative while driving conditions
have been dangerous so too can be the
shoveling doctors suspect an Illinois
man died of a heart attack while
removing snow when you start having
chest pain or chest discomfort you
should stop if you start feeling really
short of breath or feeling light-headed
or nauseous or start breaking into a
sweat those are signs are very
concerning
while the seasons biggest snowfall
wasn't crippling for Chicago the city
wasn't taking things lightly
all public schools were closed hundreds
of plow trucks were on the roads and
these firefighters spent the day digging
out fire hydrants another first
responder in Milwaukee answered the call
officer jason schneider and his dad used
a metal detector to help a nurse find
her wedding ring that fell into a
snowbank but the reunions will have to
wait for some of those travelers still
stranded here at O'Hare if this happened
in Alabama ppb out Brian disability
insurance and life insurance and taking
out burial policies because the end of
days would be soon with as much as six
more inches of snowfall possible
this weekend whether traveling by car or
by air the best advice is to take plenty
of time Alex Dean Reynolds in Chicago
thanks team